[Musica]
il giorno allora il tema della giornata
di oggi lo sapete era dice al futuro io
vivo all'estero lavoro all'estero quando
mi parlano di treviso e delle delle mie
radici ba mi viene un colpo allo stomaco
perché se siete stati anche voi un pò in
astinenza da radicchio potete sapere
quanto difficile sia ecco però penso che
di radicchio siate esperti anche voi non
è di questo che voglio parlarvi voglio
parlarvi di quello che mi tiene lontana
dal treviso e darà di più voglio
parlarvi dal mio lavoro mi occupo di
scienza appunto e quindi vi parlerò
delle radici della scienza allora di
solito quando si parla di scienza spesso
nel dibattito pubblico sia in mente più
tecnologia no
le applicazioni della scienza le cose di
cui mi occupo io invece sono lontane
delle applicazioni mi occupo di fisica
teorica e mi occupo di cercare di
studiare l'universo su grandissima scala
e lo spazio e il tempo sulla scala più
piccola dove agiscono le leggi della
meccanica quantistica
cerco di costruire una nuova teoria che
metto tutte queste cose assieme
come si fa si fa ovviamente con la
matematica si fa scrivendo equazioni ma
soprattutto quello che noi facciamo
quando discutiamo quando cerchiamo di
costruire queste nuove teorie quello che
stiamo facendo è cercare un nuovo modo
per vedere il mondo una nuova visione un
nuovo modo per pensare come funziona il
mondo attorno a noi
ecco allora costruire una nuova teoria è
un po come costruire un edificio è un
sottile gioco di equilibri in cui tutto
deve stare in armonia
ma attenzione perché la scienza non è
semplicemente un processo cumulativo in
cui costruisco aggiungendo un piano uno
sopra l'altro quello che noi facciamo vi
dicevo e fisica fondamentale
significa che andiamo a guardare le
fondamenta andiamo a guardare se alla
base del nostro edificio
magari c'è qualche palo che adesso è
marcio e bisogna sostituirlo
oppure potrebbe succedere che questo
edificio continua a crescere a
espandersi ea un certo punto in questo
gioco di equilibri
l'edificio non può già più su uno di
questi pilastri e allora può succedere
che sia meglio togliere completamente
questo pilastro quindi alla base della
scienza c'è sempre un rimettere in
questione
ogni cosa ogni cosa perfino le proprie
radici perfino alle proprie fondamenta
quando facciamo questo all'inizio è
sempre un atto di ribellione allora a me
viene da pensare a quel momento nella
storia in cui per la prima volta almeno
per quello che noi sappiamo
qualcuno ha fatto questo atto di
coraggio questo atto di ribellione
c'è un momento nella storia dell'umanità
e nella storia del pensiero in cui si
crea qualcosa di nuovo in cui per la
prima volta invece che il sapere invece
invece il sapere non cresce più per un
atto di fede
gli allievi agli allievi non viene più
che richiesto di imparare a memoria
quello che gli insegna il proprio
maestro alla fede si sostituisce
il pensiero critico se volete alla fede
si sostituisce la fiducia la fiducia non
solo che a l'allievo verso il maestro
banche del maestro verso da allievo che
si mette sullo stesso piano e permette
al suo allievo di criticarlo allora vi
dicevo c'è un momento nella storia
dell'umanità in cui questo per quello
che noi sappiamo è successo per la prima
volta ed è sulle sponde di quella che è
oggi la turchia a mileto
siamo nel sesto secolo avanti cristo e
milito vive quello che al tempo era il
più grande e sapiente del tempo talete
la scuola di miletto e la scuola di
fondata da talete si caratterizza
proprio per questo dibattito interno gli
studenti di talete anassimene
anassimandro prendono le teorie di
talete le assorbono fanno una specie di
quello che chiama un gesto d'amore
perché solamente nel momento in cui si
conosce profondamente la teoria sulla
quale si sta lavorando si può capire
dove si può andare a cambiarla per
rendere migliore questo fanno gli
allievi di talete
cambiano le teorie del loro maestro però
in questo modo le rendono vive danno la
possibilità a queste teorie di
continuare nel tempo ea migliorarsi
allora succede anche qualcos'altro a
miletto succede che per la prima volta
appunto si sostituisce ad un atto di
fede ha una spiegazione data in termini
di qualche storia su qualche divinità si
sostituisce appunto dicevamo il pensiero
critico
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che se pioveva
se c'era un tuono precedentemente veniva
il sacerdote ci raccontava che si cela
zeus che si era arrabbiato aveva
scagliato il tuono aveva fatto venire la
pioggia per la prima volta ai massim
andro propone
che la pioggia sia un fenomeno naturale
sia un fenomeno che possiamo capire
razionalmente e propone che ci sia tutto
un ciclo dell'acqua che lo spiega
propone anche altre teorie altre teorie
per l'appunto teorie naturalistiche che
permettono di spiegare i fenomeni
naturali
allora vedete a mileto
non ci sono più le leggi della natura le
leggi del cielo date dagli idee e dai
sacerdoti ma ci sono delle leggi della
natura che gli uomini costruiscono
discutendo tra di loro
allora non è un caso che questo succeda
proprio nello stesso posto in cui c'è il
primo parlamento dell'umanità a mileto
c'è un anfiteatro in cui rappresentante
delle diverse città joniche si trovavano
per discutere delle leggi comuni quindi
non più è una divinità un sacerdote che
detta le leggi ma un insieme di uomini
che crea degli e leggi per gli uomini
crea delle leggi discutendo
incontrandosi e mileto è infatti un
punto di incontro è il collegamento tra
l'oriente arrivano le carovane dei
mercanti dall'oriente dall'asia e da
mileto partono poi coloni che
arriveranno nel sud dell'italia no
mileto è anche il posto dove arriva il
sapere antico al tempo sapere degli
egiziani di babilonia era già un sapere
antico di cui però a mileto si discute
si ha notizia allora tutte queste questi
fattori
il fatto che ci sia una discussione
democratica delle leggi
il fatto che
ci sia un mescolamento di genti non sono
forse proprio questi stessi fattori che
hanno reso più di mille anni più tardi
venezia quell'incredibile luogo la
chiamavano la porta d'oriente no era il
luogo dove popoli diversi si
incontravano arrivavano gente arrivava
gente da tutto il mondo e da venezia
partivano i mercanti in tutte le
direzioni a cercare nuove merce
incontrare nuovi popoli venezia era una
repubblica le leggi venivano discusse
maniera laica
quindi grazie a questo
venezia è diventato il centro in cui
venivano stampati i libri scientifici
che altrimenti sarebbero stati messi a
luogo al rogo in altri posti a venezia
venivano stampati venivano distribuiti
in tutta europa è sempre la laicità
l'indipendenza dalla chiesa ha permesso
la fondazione di una delle più antiche
università del mondo studenti che
fuggivano da bologna e dalle altre città
dove devono essere perseguiti dal potere
religioso trovavano rifugio a venezia e
nel da repubblica veneziana quindi
abbiamo anche un centro scientifico
ecco tutti questi valori
la ribellione ribellione colta di cui
parlavo prima la laicità la democrazia
l'apertura il mescolamento questi sono
tutti valori che posso chiamare le mie
radici che attenzione quando parliamo di
radici non parliamo mai del passato
non voglio portarmi dietro tutto il
passato non voglio portarmi dietro le
vele guerra e l'odio
quando parliamo di redi ci facciamo una
scelta
facciamo una scelta dei valori che sono
importanti per noi oggi per il presente
per il futuro allora questi sono valori
che io posso portare con me posso
portarli nella comunità scientifica
nella quale lavoro e nella quale vivo
questa grande famiglia di ricercatori
accomunati dalla passione per qualche
per qualche teoria strana per qualche
sfida scientifica
ho avuto la fortuna di lavorare in
questo ambiente dove possono incontrare
e lavorare assieme come li chiamo i miei
fratelli accademici
tanta è la condivisione passa intere
giornate a discutere assieme questi
fratelli accademici vengono da tutto il
mondo
questa ricchezza umana è una delle cose
che amo di più nel mio lavoro
ecco vi racconto tutto questo con
emozione perché mi sono resa conto che
un momento un po particolare della mia
vita mi sono resa conto che sono
esattamente tanti anni che sono stata
via da treviso quanti quelli che ho
vissuto qui sono andata via ho
conosciuto persone diverse
sono cresciuta sono anche cambiata non
c'è più un posto unico che posso
chiamare casa
ci sono tante case però non sono solo io
che sono cambiate anche treviso cambia
anche treviso per fortuna nonostante le
sacche di ignoranza di razzismo e di
fascismo che purtroppo ancora ci sono
nonostante tutto questo c'è una città
che cresce che si apre una città più
colorata e una citta che crea e io in
questa città posso ancora sentirmi a
casa
[Applauso]